foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled
using single B technology to develop
lead antibody molecules on gpcr Targets
this webinar is part of the sixth annual
event in the drug Discovery and
development virtual event series and I'm
Susie Valdez of lab roots and I will be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labroots and sponsored by Dima biotech
for more information about biotech
please go to dimabio.com now let's get
started before we begin I want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to First participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our new live chat feature during this
presentation you can find that live chat
located on the left of your screen you
can also participate by submitting as
many questions as you want during this
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
submit we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of this
presentation you will also notice that
the sponsor has provided a survey
located at the right of the abstract
this survey will be available during
both the live session and the on-demand
period now if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
simply click on the help desk button
located at the top of your screen within
the navigation bar or from the lobby and
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits link
located at the abstract tab from the
menu at the left of your screen and
follow the process to obtain those
credits I now present today's speaker Dr
dong Hui ma Dima biotechnology LTD CEO
for a complete biography of all of our
speakers please visit the presenter tab
from the menu at the left of your screen
Dr ma welcome
UE now begin your presentation
hello everybody
um it's very Greek pleasure for me to
present the mobile text single B
technology and also how we utilize this
technology to develop lead antibody
molecules
um therapeutic drug targets especially
on gpcr targets I'm the CEO from Dima
biotech I'm donkey Ma
biotech is about technology company
focused primarily on the heat to lead
stage of antibody drug discovery
and in today's talk I will divide my
talk into three sessions the first
session I will disclose some of our
technology platforms
um like a therapeutic lead antibody
Discovery include how we make functional
proteins use dimpro and how we clone the
IGG genes directly from B cells by using
uh dmab single B technology platform and
how we utilize and by many display
platform D library for antibody
engineering and the second part of the
talk I'm going to Showcase one of the
example how we utilize dmas Discovery
platform to develop and criteria TCL
therapy solution for multiple normal
treatment
on the last part and also most important
part we're going to show how dmar can
help and enable biofarm companies to
discover and help them to find more lead
antibody molecule to help them to push
more quickly of their pipeline to
clinical trials
this is our Discovery procedure for
therapeutic lead antibodies in the first
part we'll make the best and Native
functional proteins as emailing to
immunize animal now we build up a high
Superior assay to find the best leads
heat and then we use our dmap technology
single bit technology to clone the IGG
Gene after ranking the the best
molecules then we choose the lead for
further optimization with our D Library
technology we can do a criminalization
Affinity maturation or other even like
de-risk some of the amino acids like a
system from the CDR region by using our
D Library technology
uh in the next couple of slides we're
going to show uh in detail how we
utilize our Discovery platform for
therapeutically lead anybody Discovery
from the protein part to the antibody
engineering side
for a functional proteins especially for
those uh therapeutical leader antibodies
for antibody drug more than 90 percent
of the drug targets antibody drug
targets they are transmembrane protein
according to the complexity of their
transmembrane domains they can be
divided into two group of proteins
single transmembrane protein and the
multi-transmembrane protein
so single transmembrane protein the
preparation the well-established
Technologies basically people use the
extracellular domain that cut it out and
fuse with the heat or FC domain and
expressing the mammalian cell so by this
approach they can mimic the native
structure and a number of FDA approved
drugs have been successfully developed
by this approach
and for multitransmembrane protein
there's a lot of challenges especially
the multi-transmembrane domain they are
highly hydrophobic they cannot purify
into high Purity in aqueous solution so
they tend to form aggregate so in the
past if people want to develop a high
quality therapeutic antibodies most of
time people use wholesale immunization
or wholesale Elisa to identify the best
molecule but the problem is when you
analyze this whole cell into animal some
of the cytosolic protein and the nuclear
protein also can be released to the
animal body and then they will also
activate the immune response the
creative background antibodies so they
will create the issues so Dima to
address these issues we develop our own
dimpro different Technology Solutions
like a vlp virus like particles exosome
MMP detergent solution approach or
nanodis technology in the next couple of
slides are going to get
explain them you lose them into detail
this is our ecd um fusion protein
technology platform basically uh we uh
we purify the protein from hdk
suspension cell system and after purify
them if to ensure their functioning so
if the protein has an authentic Native
ligand or receptor we also Express the
receptor ligand and to a individual
binding acid to ensure they are native
structure if the particular target has a
FDA approved or a clinical trial
antibody drug will also synthesize about
similar drugs to bind to the antigen to
ensure the native structure currently we
already made and validate more than one
thousand therapeutic Target proteins in
this by using this approach
for multitransmembrane protein edema has
two major categories of solutions and
for the solution one basically we
express the fullness protein into my
mining cell and we may remembering
nanoparticles in this nanoparticle
vesicle format they can be utilized for
different acids like Eliza or even flow
barometric acid
and for the um for this group of uh
technology the First Technology we call
the mlmp membrane nanoparticles
uh this the strategies are very simple
first we express the fullness
transmembrane protein on the cell
surface then we use a mechanical force
to break the cell then separate the
membrane fraction and the cytosolic and
the nuclear fraction
out then the membrane fraction will make
a small nanoparticles so it can be used
for the downstream assay or immunization
so they won't have a contamination of
the cytosolic protein nuclear protein
the verse like a particle vlps and the
exosomes are the similar technology the
mechanisms are very similar for vlp
basically we co-express our multi-time
membrane protein which uh virus capacity
protein like a gag so when the virus
capsid protein first in in the cell so
they tend to self-assemble into a
vesicles and they were bodied out from
cell surface when they buy it out the
multi-transmitter membrane protein will
call like a migrate out with these
nanoparticles so by this way you can
produce the real piece the diameter of
the vlps normally a 150 nanometer in
diameter exosome is a similar approach
this is an example of um
this is the example of by using our MMP
technology produced
nanoparticles so uh basically we create
an MMP uh for a cloudian 6 which is a
four test membrane domain protein so
after we made them it can be utilized
for Eliza on the left also can be used
for flow setometry we here we call the
flow variometry analysis from this data
on the left you can see more than 97
percent of the vesicles contain our
Target protein so they are highly evenly
distributed on a cell surface
even though uh this um the solution one
a series of technology is a very uh
highly uh like
is very good but there are also issues
because during purify these vesicles
some of the like housekeeping Gene and
the cell membrane from the host cell
they'll also co-purified
and when you analyze the animal you also
create the background antibodies so so
the next step is is how can we purify
freelance membrane protein in Native
structure and also in highly purified
format here we have a two demo I have
two different technology Technical
Solutions the first is called a nanodisc
and second is a detergent solubilization
approach for detergent approach this has
been taxes owed technology basically by
screening different detergent you can
solubilize the membrane and also the
multi-transmembrane protein by forming
myself
the problem with this detergent approach
so you cannot remove those detergents
when you remove them the membrane
protein tend to form Aggregate and lost
the function so when you do use the
determine containing and proteins for
lifestyle image for lifestyle acid it
will also kill cell the Nano disk
technology is a new technology developed
in around the 2000 in membrane research
field
during 2000 the research scientists find
in the um in the serum there's some of
the
like a liver protein they have a special
feature when they incubate with Marine
cell membrane they can dissemble the
membrane and form a small disk and this
small disk normally is a 5 to 15
nanometer in diameter in the center they
have the liver by layer and also one
chargement protein in the center so you
can use a chromatography to purify this
protein and also they are highly stable
so um in Pima we utilize and different
technology for Nano disk preparation we
use a synthetical polymer which is
different from the the traditional
approach by using membrane scaffold
protein like APO A1 or like some of the
LDL protein
foreign
example of
our technology versus MSP Nano disk
technology you can see on the left side
we use our technology prepared cloud in
sex
um on the SDS page is highly like a
homogeneous a single band purified and
can be used for Elisa acid on the right
side
this uh the figure I adapt from JBC
paper they use MSP so basically uh you
can purify the target protein and also
you can see the carry out co-purify some
large amount of this scaffold protein
MSP so when you use this technology for
immunization it will create also
background anybody against this as msps
but the the benefit of our technology we
don't have this uh like container
MSP proteins
and uh even though um female biotech is
an antibody company we focus a lot on
the protein function of protein
development because we truly believe
to get the best antibody you need and
best functional protein as a Immunology
for development
the next couple slides I'm going to uh
disclose our technology on single B
platform
for monoclonal antibody development
there's a different platforms like from
traditional hybridoma phase Easter
display to the most recent Cutting Edge
technological single B
here's a demon biotech's a single B
technology platform our development
process first we analyze the animal with
the best protein when the animal gets a
good immune response then we will
collect the pbmc and the spinner side
and then we use the purified Target
protein to do an enrichment to collect
only those Target B cells then we see
all these B cells on to a 96 well plate
each well we only see the one cell now
we cultivate this single B with our dmas
the Preparatory single uh the Visa
culture media during 7 to 14 days after
cultivation time one B cell will
multiply and amplify from one cell to
100 to 200 cell and also they secrete
the antibody into the calcium medium
after that after assay analysis like for
example Elisa or flow certometer
blocking or activation assay we identify
the positive clones now we clone the
gene by PCR or next Generation
sequencing to further validate the
protein
so um anybody
and since our technology is highly
effective in most of case
we don't need all the B cells to do the
screening so in most of the case we only
take 120s or 140s of the total B cells
in all collected uh like a b cells uh
pool for one round of screening in one
round screening in most of cases we get
like a several hundred possible clones
for the rest of the Visa we will store
them in liquid hydrogen for future
screening so in the future if we need
more clones we can always retrieve those
uh like uh B cells from liquid nitrogen
after around the 30 days of like a
development process so we get a new
clones so this is the powerful
technology we call the B cell library
technology
in the D libraries comparing to
traditional hybridoma platform
our dmaps has a lot of different
Advantage the major two advantages first
it is a high success rate so during the
past according to our experience the
more than 300 targets certainly targeted
of thousands of molecules of
successories is more than 90 percent and
another uh like uh the advantage is our
development time is much shorter it's
only one half of the hyperdoma type we
only need three to four months this will
also included immunization type
right now on the market there's a number
of different single B uh cloning
platform what is the difference between
our platform versus other platform
here's a compilation
so uh Beacon platform is a very popular
single B uh Colony technology and this
technology developed by Berkeley light
basically uh the theory of the mechanism
of this technology is very simple the
user highly clarified uh sort of like a
fact sorting machine they can sort
thousands of millions of B cells and
then disseminate these cells onto a
glass slide on this class slide they
create uh like a thousands of like small
Wells for each while they can hold one
cell and also hold several nanometers of
culture media with the detection
reagents
after 24 hours of incubation this B cell
is to create antibody and also the react
with the detection reagent if they are
positive then they directly clone the
gene from this single B cell by PCR or
next Generation sequence
uh even though this technology is very
uh powerful and robustic but there's a
two uh challenges the first challenge is
on the essay part so they only have a
several nanometer culture media so they
cannot do uh like a traditional assay
like Eliza flow cytometry so they have
to use a miniaturize the assay to do the
analysis Second Challenge is that they
got the CDA from a single B cell so if
there were any aerosol contamination
they will have issues
the same for the oil droplet platform
which I mean by some of the company and
the difference they don't use a glass
slide is to use oil droplet to seal one
cell
the dmas technology is different so
basically after we see the wine cell on
the next single plate we cultivate the
cell for uh seven to fourteen days
in this cultivation media we let the
cell grow from one cell to 100 to 200
cells so um in the uh one well of this
calcium latent we get enough antibody to
do traditional essay like Eliza or
fluorescent I say and also the B cell
number is 100 from one cell to 100 to
200 cells so this perfectly avoid some
of the issues with other technology
platform and
for the cloning part so we already have
100 and 200 B cells as a sitting
template so we are more resistant to the
aerosol contamination
so um this is uh our technology
comparing to other B cell single B uh
Tech cloning platform
on the next slide I'm going to uh show
how after we identify the top lead how
we to do optimization with our antibody
engineering platform we call the D
Library where money is play for the form
other the library platform can do
multiple different applications here we
just showcase how we use this technology
platform to do antibody
decriminalization
for the library to do antibody
humanization is a little bit different
from the traditional way for most of the
case when biofarm or other cro company
to do antibody criminalization what that
would normally lead to is they use a
computer aided like designing the first
like a model in the three-dimensional
structure I need to leave it like a bike
mutation to find the couple of like
potential by rational design from a
couple of potential good lead for
humanization
for our approach we use the experimental
approach first we construct a human IGG
Gemini framework Library so in this
Library so we got several hundred of our
human IG germ lines framework part then
we graph the parental from mouse or
rabbit or from like a llama so cdridge
into this library then we express the
library onto the cell surface or hk293
cells
and then we use um like the target
protein to enrich this surface Quest
Iggs
after enrichment we can find the better
the high Affinity binders by this using
this day Library approach so by one
screening we cannot only finish the
humanization and also we can find the
the best binder through this approach
here's the one case we developed an
anti-bcma rapid humanized molecule so uh
from this data you can see the parental
antibodies already show very high
binding Affinity in KD value is 0.267
nano or more but after several round of
screening we can identify a molecule the
best molecule to the pycamore range the
Affinity increase almost 18 volts
this is a another case so anti-ca can 5
rapid motor car antibody after several
round of like a screening we identify a
molecule the top of molecule to bigger
mode range the Affinity increase almost
19 fold so this is the beauty of our
technology for one application for
humanization definitely our technology
can also utilize for CDR region like for
the affinity and maturation and also for
d-risk some of the amino acid existing
and to uh for like by saturated mutation
approach
in the past I already show our
development capacity and the next couple
of slides I'm going to Showcase how we
utilize our dmas development technology
platform to develop an anti-gprc 5D car
T Cell Therapy approach for multiple
melanoma treatment
at the first stage of development we use
our d-maps find a nine top lead
molecules and we did a humanization
after humanize of the all these nine
antibodies we um we try to mimic in the
car key scenario so we we construct into
scfv uh like a structure and we did the
Affinity ranking by facts
um from this data you can see After
Effects Affinity evaluation several of
our molecules shows so much better
binding capability comparing to the
reference molecule which is Eureka's
molecule March 109 which is in clinical
trial so the red arrow showed the
reference molecule
and also we did the individual tumor
cell killing from this you move to a
tumor cell killing from the um like high
effector to tumor cell ratio versus the
low ratio you can see the red like Arrow
indicators reference
under the high we can not we don't see
much difference but at a low ratio you
can see several of our molecules exhibit
much uh better tumor cell killing
efficiency comparing to the reference
So based on this data we choose three
molecules uh push forward for individual
assay data oh in Vivo as a data on
animal study
so this is the animal data and the
animal survival data so after graph the
tumor cells mm 1.s is a multiple myeloma
tumor cell onto mice and then we Infuse
with the car T construct
from this data you can see after 93 days
the red box labeled a group of Maestra
they were still survived and they can
still suppress the tumor cells
and um to ensure
we ensure this
um like a construct when they Infuse I
mean to the patient to the treatment
with patient they are targeted highly
specific they don't have off Target like
a binding or killing effects so we also
need like a specificity On Target cell
evaluation
this is our data basically uh we first
construct and cardiacate with the
reference and also our three different
uh car constructs
g0507 and the zero nine
and we incubate our card jacket cell
with the with the like a different tumor
cell line and also two of the healthy
people's pbmc and see whether this
conjective cell can only activate by the
gprc5d expression cells from this data
you can see all these different
construct shows the specificity only
towards the
gprc5d expression cells they don't show
off Target to the like pbmc normal
people sell or to other tumor cells so
this shows the specificity and another
interesting sense that you can see are
t07 shows a much stronger activation by
incubate with the native tumor cell line
this uh rpmi
8226 cell and comparing to the reference
so we choose this cell collaborator with
a party company
in Guangzhou in China so right now this
project is in IIT clinical trial
in the past I show our technology
platform and also showcase one example
how we utilize this technology to
develop and like a pre-colonical
candidate for clinical trial so in the
next couple slides I'm going to show how
dma can enable and how about Pharma
company for the lead antibody Discovery
and what is our business solution
different from other cro companies
basically we provide the next day and a
real risk solution for biofarm companies
foreign in the past for bathroom company
when they try to develop and need a
therapeutical Target what they do is uh
they either use internal R D team or cro
companies to develop a leader antibody
molecule so um for these two approach
first you have to uh whether you CL I
mean internal you have to invest either
equipment or paid sell company with a
high upfront payment after a couple of
months of waiting then you will see
whether it's a good result or batteries
or because for any biological project
there's a risk of a failure so after
several months if the project doesn't uh
go through well and you both waste the
money and also the time for the projects
so there's a lot of risk
FEMA uh we what we do is a little bit
different from this approach basically
always thinking
um right now what we do is uh we invest
our own money to develop all these uh
like a certificate Target leader
molecule development so we pretty and
develop all these Targets on the leader
molecules and put this uh put this
molecule on shelf so when the bell Farms
see our list our list of the targets if
they have any interest on one of the
targets we can shift the antibody next
day to the Bell Farm Company they can
evaluate internally internally with
their assay so whether the particular
molecule works for the
I think so by this way and so basically
it's a zero risk so if it works then we
sign the agreement on contract
so this can save a perform company at
least eight months time in development
time and
um so if a platform company needs more
molecules we also we also have liquid
nitrogen store the B cells which have
been validated by like this little
molecule so we can screen another round
this only takes a certain uh 30 days
right now we already are finished here
up to 250 druggable targets with
thousands of lead molecules
so uh you are welcome to uh come to us
and uh see whether there's any Targets
in your interest
is more a better company and focus on
the products so we already have uh 250
drivable targets uh available on shelf
for the power farm for leader molecules
uh thousands of leader molecules we also
provide products for full-lengths
multitasker membrane protein either in
vlp MMP or nanodisc format and other
products also we can offer so if you are
interested you can always go to dmas
website 3w dot d
mobile.com to see whether you have any
interest product for you and if you have
any question you can I mean you can ask
in the later session or you can send the
email to me personally for to my email
address or you can call me
today's talk if you have any questions I
would like to take questions thank you
thank you Dr moff that informative
presentation we will now start the Q a
portion of this webinar if you have any
questions you want to ask please do so
now just click on that ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen so let's get started it looks
like we already have some questions
coming in Dr ma comparing to other
single cloning Technologies available in
the market what are the special features
and advantages to deem AB platform
yeah for gmap uh technology platform
basically uh the major uh difference
um there's a one uh so there's a couple
of different technological platforms as
I mentioned in my presentation like uh
beacon work from Berkeley light and uh
you know another is uh
microfluiders uh oil droplet technology
platform so our technology platform the
major difference is that we do have an
seven to like 14 days cultivation for
the Beast the B cell initiative is
received into a 96 well played so we
have our
um like our own developed proprietary
technology for b-cell cultivation media
so during this cultivation time the BCL
windshield will cultivate I mean
Amplified to 100 200 cells so um we can
do a regular assay like Eliza or fax or
broadcasting or even some activation I
see you're in the circulating
for Beacon and the other technology
platform the user are single cell to do
this so they only can provide like a
silver nanometers so those um like a
regular assay they cannot perform so
that's one difference another thing is
uh we amplify the cell from one cell to
100 cells so our like a cloning stage we
um we get the IGG team from this uh 100
like a b cells and so our more we are
more resistant to the like aerosol
contamination during PCR or nitrogen
sequencing so that's um two major
difference comparing to other platform
yeah
thank you so much
with the mobile
to enlisten its deem AB clones for
therapeutic purposes
yeah
um we in the past we have been working
with a number of like
um you know um bathroom companies and so
um you know for different platform
companies and they have a different
Market needs
um we we are pretty flexible for the
business term and we can you know if
some performance company they want like
uh work with us as a strategic partner
that's also we do have this uh like a uh
in a Partners in the past and also we do
have platform companies and they want to
like buy out like the uh the IP for the
Clone that's also workable for with us
and also uh we do also have a platform
company working with us uh they pay us
you know kind of a milestone uh payment
uh like uh way so that also we do have a
company working in this way yeah
thank you so much and I want to thank
our audience for these great questions
will Dima bio offer standard products
for
multi-transmembrane proteins in Nano
disk format
uh yes we do offer
um so
um we do initiate our own like uh
product pipeline for this nanodisk
especially for
um like uh gpcrs and uh some of the like
iron channels so um currently we are
offering more than 50 like already on
shelf uh purified multi
multi-transmembrane proteins uh to the
customer we do also offer like
um
customized products if people do want
like a produce
multi-trans membrane protein gpcrs for
their own Target we can also provide a
service for this yeah
thank you so much it looks like we have
one more question coming in what are the
special features about demo bios
nanodisk technology
yeah
um for the common uh like a traditional
Nano District technology which uh were
um initially developed in like a 2000 by
uh in like a memory membrane protein
research field people normally use multi
membrane scaffold protein as like a like
a help to form this nanodisk uh like an
LDL or HDL this like an APO A1 protein
to do this so what do we do a little bit
differently uh we use an uh
um polymer to make this another disk so
um because we use this as a second
polymer so when we use this nanodisk for
immunization or screening so we we get
less background like signals because
those
MSP membrane scaffold protein like April
A1 they also can create anybody's doing
immunization or create background during
like a screening so that's quite a
different from our analytics technology
from the other technology so I do have
an example in
in representation there's a one slide
that shows our
um like a purified protein is showing
highly homogeneous a single band and the
other like MSP technology for nanoges
they have multiple Brands yeah
drama I want to thank you for your
presentation today would you like to
provide any closing remarks to our
audience before we go
yeah uh thank you everybody to attend uh
today laborers as this presentation I
think it's a very good opportunity to
share our technology and also uh we
would help we also enable our customers
especially bio Farm companies and the
research institute scientists to help
them to develop a high quality model
anybody for Sharp Target Target and also
develop some like technology for new
research yeah thank you
we want to thank you again and for your
important research and before we go I
want to thank our audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions I'd also like to thank our
sponsored Dima biotech for sponsoring
today's webinar questions we did not
have time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by our speaker via the contact
information provided at the time of
registration and this webcast can be
viewed on demand for two years until
February 22nd 2025. laboratory alert you
via email when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone bye